welcome to this video playing and Tommy
duck from Australia namen des Andrew
Brown Commission must Andrew Brown don't
know him but a plate in before scoring
two wins let's see yeah recently scored
with this nicely let's play that again
yeah night a success on one of the
better lines here rock g6 now is the
move hmm Keys I'm sacrificing okay but
just just briefly let's consider what
this means is in its not like and very
instant to win for white I have played
similar positions before and like has
got some compensation it's not it's not
probably not enough but it's not so
clear can I go here to see three all the
way it's got lots of peace activity
not the same Bishop Bishop e6 looks like
the normal rules 95 now I just spotted
it two nite c5 okay if I go King c3
maybe 96 I don't really I cannot protect
it otherwise he will even get there
anyway he will get back upon Jeff as
mentioned it's not so easy not so easy
at all
if i take it between okay come on let's
let's let's be greedy not if i go kinky
too and it looks like like yuck but i
want to i want to keep the material here
if i go Bishop b5 shower be three looks
looks like looks like too much yeah I'm
still Knight c3
Wow Knight c3 checking d2e for Bishop b5
maybe this is still ok
hmm ok I didn't I didn't think about
that moose my bishop is almost trapped
this is the point King III maybe this
even Bishop age 67 discs as possible
it's almost made rookie wonders Knight
c3
yeah that's a strong move 96 simple but
strong okay if he's got a mate then
nicely played
hard to say maybe even king d 2 is not
good and this is an incorrect opening
for black buckets it's tricky to play of
this level okay y'all know is good efore
check
yeah very very ugly just not sure that
this is the best what he did I mean
95-93 ha yeah this is like dodging
bullets all the time check of course I'm
glad if I'm not just not mated here I
should have taken c6 ah this was much
better now we can take and play rock the
aid gag shoot this was much better much
better even playable I guess check yeah
maybe that's also stood okay I really
thought I'm lost I was surprised that
I'm still in the game okay there should
be seven beckham this is the problem
the moment is not immediately
threatening to to win chief g4 Bishop g2
if it takes Bishop d3 and I'm okay yeah
somehow I'm still alive but it did it
did cost enormous amount of time yeah
this is completely okay check check time
morning
yeah just just completely drawn gras our
third ground Arthur on yeah that's nice
I mean you could win on time I'm just on
10 seconds yeah well I don't know how I
survived this probably he let's let a
couple of wind slip wow you know as
mentioned this is not really a really ok
for black but it's it's tricky obviously
rooked you all know the conference to
play d1 now maybe this one it sir I
never never really analyzed this line
and I always thought okay if someone
plays that I'll figure it out over the
board but this applies to to classical
time controls and blood sets it's tricky
yeah and this immediately lends me into
into trouble it seems yeah computer
instantly goes down to zero evaluation
while it was on plus one point something
before and here wow it's a it's just
like dodging bullets it gives Bishop
takes a 5s okay again and this probably
leads to disaster yeah it does but and
what I don't understand is I was a
socialist but here i thought no i
thought night c2 would be a problem but
of course this is also hanging
interesting
the draw Josh line as Bishop d5 yeah Wow
impossible to analyze now everything's
hanging yeah and this it looked it
looked looked bad i know this is really
a strong move really strong it threatens
to to trap this bishop and I don't have
a move I really don't have one this
should probably lose but it's not easy F
five wins I was even thinking that hey
this is winning it looks like it looks
completely crazy here but this seems
less no made check check compass on 000
yeah very hard to say but f5 is just
good I need to say that just threatening
this andrew c 8 and I'm toast NTM yeah
funny enough it's not the clear-cut win
at least after a couple of seconds of
computer yes and now I made a big
mistake here I need to take on c6 I
thought I forgot about doing that really
the ideas that now d 8 is controlled and
I don't have any problems at all but the
compass saying that night oops Knight c3
is an issue I didn't consider that one
but I had this one nerd hmm
okay this is not nice at all yeah i'm
still in and slide trouble okay but I
need to take them check check yeah funny
enough it just slide edge from black
according to the comp the nerve I really
come I mean relative to the
circumstances I defended relative
chatting Wow while that intense game
thanks for watching